last year I called the pixel three Excel
the worst flash of phone I've ever used
I admit I was very harsh in my review
which got a lot of hateful comments but
I have to stand by my opinions not only
because the three Excel had a lot of
software issues but because it was also
quite a bit behind hardware wise when
you consider the $900 price point so
what about half a year later now that
Google has released the three eight and
three Axl well to be honest my mind is
completely changed this time around and
this time I'm calling the three Axl
budget perfection the 3a doesn't have
top aligned specs like the pixel three
the CPU is a bit weaker the graphics are
even behind the pixel two and the
display is of lower quality as are the
speakers there's no wireless charging no
IP water resistance rating and the phone
is made out of plastic but a half the
price all of those sins are forgiven and
if you compare the features to other
similarly priced phones the 3a
really shines now there are a few things
that I wish Google did differently and
there are some people who I wouldn't
recommend it to which I'll cover in just
a bit but overall this phone as the
winner and I would highly recommend it I
don't want to get too much into specs
but we have the same rear cameras with a
single front that's wider than the pixel
3 standard which was a smart move we
have a rear fingerprint scanner Google
assistant squeeze feature and the same 4
gigabytes of RAM what really matters is
the real world experience what's it like
using the phone day-to-day and I have to
say that is really good no it's not as
good as a proper flagship like the s10
plus or the 7 Pro but is still good and
for the price tag it's excellent brand
management wasn't an issue for me and
the you I was actually smoother than the
pixel threes the CPU is slower so it's
not that but it's actually thanks to
Google optimizing and fixing software
bugs ever since their flagship launched
Google made a smart choice to spend
money where matters and is most
noticeable the camera the display and
the speakers the things that you
actually interact with day to day as I
already mentioned the display the
speakers aren't as good as the pixel
threes but the oullette screen and
stereo speakers definitely get close and
fight way above their price point the
photo quality is really good basically
the same as the pixel threes the
algorithms have been tweaked over time
and I notice the images don't have the
same strong bias towards cool white
balances which I'm glad they tweaked
since we have
a single lens camera zoom shots are
still behind phones with a dedicated
telephoto lens but because of Google's
photo staff team it looks better than
other single systems like Dai Quentin
ours portrait photos oddly now use a 2 x
digital crop instead of the 1.25 times
the pixel 3 use I really like the slight
crop of the pixel 3 a limited distortion
for close-ups but still gave a high
quality great looking wide portrait
video recording is still a few years
behind the flagships with no 4k 60 and
poor mic quality but that's passable at
this price point the main takeaway is
that this phone will take better
standard photos than any phone under
$500 and many that are far more
expensive my only other complaint is the
shutter lag it seems worse than the
pixel 3 and far behind the flagships and
this side-by-side i press a shutter
right when Ilan was at the top of the
swing the iPhone grab the image
instantly every single time since it's
actually consistently taking photos and
just saves the photo when you press the
Samsung and oneplus are behind but
nowhere near as much as a 3a XL which
took the image almost a second later I
complained about this in my sm+ review
since I noticed myself missing shots on
my kids in action which I probably
wouldn't have with iPhone if you have
little kids pets or shoot other quick
moving subjects this could be a
deal-breaker check out our detailed
photo comparison to see how it stacks up
to three very impressive flagships after
this video let's get back to the design
of this phone Google need it to cut
costs so the phone is made of plastic
some reviewers said it feels just as
good as the three and I can see where
they're coming from because of the
frosted back but I could definitely feel
that it's plastic as soon as I put my
hands on it what that said it doesn't
feel cheap at all and most people will
put a case on it and then there's
actually no difference what material
it's made out of because you're touching
the case on the plus side the headphone
jack is back and makes a ton of sense
why if you're buying a budget phone the
chances of you not owning Bluetooth
headphones is much higher the forehead
and chin are quite large but so are the
pixel threes after people use soft words
to cover up that huge not so the Edit
results were basically the same and at
this price point I think this design
makes sense
on the positive side the batteries are
large and that's a huge plus the three
excels is 3700 milliamp hours paired
with a less powerful thus less power
draining processor and a lower res
display meaning it will last a long time
if you're a power user on a budget it
will last see more than a full day
mister who's the boss did a battery
shoot out and the 3xl lasted for eight
hours of heavy screen on time longer
than any phone he's ever tested and even
beat out the zenfone 6 that has a five
thousand milliamp hour battery regular
user is the 3a which has a smaller
battery but a more manageable size
should last all day as well if you'll be
playing a lot of games
I'd suggest picking something else up
maybe the razor phone which is now
priced similarly if you want to know
more about gaming check out our game in
comparison to the pixel 3 after this
video so with all that said I think
Google made a genius move bringing out
the pixel 3a Excel when you consider the
price point and feature set a lot of
smart decisions were made on where to
focus and where to cut costs for most
people the 3a and 3 XL will get the job
done and I would recommend it to almost
everyone who's looking to buy at this
price point other than those who need
something with minimal camera shutter
lag or hardcore phone gamers Google has
a real winner on their hands and now
that it's at every major carrier in the
States it's gonna be in a lot of others
thanks for checking out our review if
you want to pick up a pixel 3a or three
a XL we have some links to some great
deals down in the description below
click right over here to subscribe and
if you want to see our detailed camera
comparison click right over there
this man max the max tech and I will see
you in the next video
[Music]